want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and get some amazing motivation
from
dame dash enjoy
what are some key elements of your honor
code that
one are just absolutely central to it
and that two if you could pass to the
culture
in an instant what would you pass
i mean if you have an agreement with
somebody if me and you have an agreement
i don't care what the rest of the world
looks at is bad or good
we have to honor our agreement period so
honor
means that when you agree and you guys
have
as men or a professional an adult
your word gotta mean more than anything
you know if you say you're gonna do
something you gotta do it
and that's what the street kind of was
you know it was like even though the
rest of the world doesn't believe in
certain things that were going on
there was this code you know no
snitching
you know no messing with your homies
girls no serving anyone pregnant
you know just things that were laws that
were unwritten
you know but there was honor
honor means more than anything bro and
it protects you no matter what
and i could just say that based on my
experience there ain't no streak
that's just some real the street might
like i'm a guy that maybe i
need to cease to learn honor and maybe
that's the reason why i was put in that
situation
because once i learned honor i'd be able
to affect the rest of the world like you
never know why things happen
that's about perspective right as a
professional the only way to be a
professional
is to work harder than everybody a
professional like a professional
baseball player a boxer is someone
that's better
than everyone else that's why he gets
paid so much to do it that means work
it ain't nothing professional gonna get
given to you there's some sacrifice
there's always pain
and you know it's always gonna be dark
times because that's part of business
every time you create a new business you
got to struggle a little bit and it
takes a while to build a brand it takes
about five years to be consistent
like my first five years you know i'm
not saying nothing different i've been
saying the same exact stuff
if you go look at um um backstage and
any kind of argument i had it's always
been consistent it's just people weren't
ready for it they didn't trust it
but after i've been saying it for ten
years five you know five to ten now
it's a brand i have a brand for it i'm
consistent i back it up i'm still here
i'm still up even when you know being an
independent meant
looking like you was down failing is
never failing it's always a learning
experience so
the thing about business is how deep
your pocket is i always say that like if
you got a lot of money
you could sustain these losses until
they turn into games but if you have a
short paper
if your money's not long or if you don't
have enough you have to make sure that
those losses don't kill and compromise
your pocket and
at that point you got to get creative
but when you do anything you get better
at it the more you do it and the first
time you do anything you usually don't
do it correct
so it's not failure it's learning
experience if you could get up and it's
like in a fight the first round you
might get knocked out
right but by the last round you get up
and knocked that person out who won you
might have lost the round but you win
the whole fight
but you got to lose some rounds in
business but at the end of the day you
want that unanimous decision
you got to keep going you got to finish
the fight the question is do you have
the stamina to finish
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief check
out my 254 series where every day for
the next 254 days
i will send you an unlisted video the
sign says it takes up to
254 days of consecutive action build a
habit so i'm going to be with you
every step of the way if you want to be
on for free 100 free is the link below
go check it out i'll see you there one
thing you have to really never do is
compare yourself to other people
absolutely that's the one thing you
can't do
i never wanted to be a part of a crowd i
always wanted to be an individual i
hated when everybody looked the same so
it was like it was corny to me to like
to like something because somebody else
liked it so i was like that guy that was
like if you like it i'm not gonna like
it
you get on the web and you check out
who's dame dash
and there's so much crap how do you deal
with that and how do you
suggest other people deal with it when
they reach a certain level of celebrity
i mean when you sign on to being
a certain level of celebrity you gotta
know they're gonna say things and you
know things are going to
get eyeballs and and get people to buy
you know what i'm saying and you know i
just i really don't care and one of the
reasons why
i think i've been successful is because
i didn't care if i cared i probably
would be too scared to promote
people that people don't want to promote
you know it takes
fearlessness to be first you know to not
move with a crowd to move along
you know and you get scrutinized by
people that do move with a crowd because
they got to make you look bad to make
themselves look good
it's all part of the game it's like a
guy that's in high school that gets all
the girls
the rest of the dudes hate him in high
school so my whole life
has been being that guy in high school
that everyone hates because i keep
taking their girls
i can understand that that's not a bad
life so that's how i look at it
the the price of success is unsuccessful
people don't like you
who cares right successful people don't
care about what another person is doing
because successful people want everybody
else to speak too exactly that's why you
know that's this whole mindset that
people don't understand right so it's
usually a bunch of unsuccessful better
bitter people and you know i was a guy
in school that you know
was got kicked out of every school i was
the class clown
you know i wasn't the guy that you would
traditionally think would be
go this far so me making it made all my
teachers look stupid
every principal that kicked me out of
school looks stupid you know
i went to south kent in connecticut um
on scholarship i didn't come back the
next year the next time i came back was
on the helicopter and i landed it on the
soccer field you know when i got kicked
out of dwight
um in the seventh grade you know my son
came back and they were asking me you
know i put my son dude
i paid full tuition plus extras for
tutoring
and they asked me to build a library i'm
like the same principal that kicked me
out
is asking me to build a library so it's
egg on all their faces
you know my success makes a lot of
people look like they were wrong
because a lot of people articulated the
fact that i wouldn't be what i am today
and either way either way i didn't care
but i think it's kind of funny it's egg
all over their face scramble
have you ever watched a james bond movie
where it doesn't look like he's losing
at some point and then he wins
or batman or iron man or any superhero
there has to be some diversity for you
to
you know overcome to win you know you
can't be a champ unless you uh you know
are in a place where you look like
you're going to lose and then you win
the pain that's going to come with being
independent you have to embrace it
because it's going to happen and also
know that the more successful you get
the more problems you're going to have
the more knots you're going to have to
untie
being a boss does not mean smooth
sailing it means having the ability
to care about other people before
yourself into untie problems untie knots
that's all it is there's it's not
business if there's not problems
there's nothing good without struggle it
just doesn't happen in all my
experiences
there hasn't been one thing that's been
successful without me feeling some pain
before it was successful
so now when there is pain i embrace it
you know i've been embracing it i'm a g
about it because i know that must mean
that if i'm cool
that you know what awaits me it's the
darkest before the dawn i don't want to
like sound corny but
that's really what that's what has to
happen on one hand yeah my mom's died it
broke my heart
but on the other hand it made me great
it's about perspective
what i learned from it how i choose to
look at you know
like sometimes i'll talk to somebody and
you know they'll be abusive
or they'll be drinking and i'll be like
you know what you do all that drinking
why you so abusive
oh my dad was drinking he was abusive
that's all i know
then you ask somebody else and they're
like a straight square they don't drink
and they're not abusive and you'd be
like
yo how come you don't drink how come
you're not abusive yo i saw my dad
it's just about perspective and that's
how i look at things with my pops i was
like i know
i'm a good dad because everything he did
i didn't like i ain't doing to my kid
i'm not gonna pass the cycle but you
know some people might look at it and
say i'm just gonna pass the cycle
because he passed it to me
perspective what does it truly mean to
be independent
just to be able to do whatever i want to
do whenever i feel like it you know what
i'm saying like i couldn't imagine like
that's why i hated school
i just you know and i'm not saying
people should hate school but i just
couldn't stand a teacher that i didn't
think was cool or smarter than me
telling me what to do
and then i had to sit there and listen
for anybody who actually
has that fear like that wakes up and
they deal with that fear and they go
into a job and they're
in between deciding if they're just
gonna go out and be independent or not
like what
are your words for them i would say
blindly do it
quit and figure it out the more
uncomfortable it makes me feel the
better
you cannot be great comfortable right
ever
see the one thing a boss has to realize
is your job isn't to take care of
yourself your job to take care of other
people so that means you have to
completely be selfless right if you're
selfish at all you're not a boss
if you don't have the ability to care
about other people before yourself
you're not a boss
people practice being bosses every day
because they're parents
you know you care more about your child
and you care about yourself that's like
your business
that's what the boss does you know i've
had to pay my staff before i pay my own
bills
because they did the work you understand
what i'm saying that's what the boss
does
confidence and not giving up is the it
makes you so lean like the
don't give a factor that makes it where
you don't care what people think
you never feel like you're being judged
you never want to be a part of a crowd
and you just you know you're just
fearless about the way you feel about
things you know and then also you got
swag you know you just
you just do what you want regardless of
what people think and it feels good
but it's tough man it's tough you know
what's tough initially
you know well when you when you when
you're brand new to independence
it's just it's a mindset it's a honestly
it's a tough mindset depends on what you
value as well
right like if you evaluate your freedom
and your happiness as
ultimate wealth or if you value
perception and physical things there's
ultimate wealth you're either gonna like
physical things is temporary so you're
gonna hustle for the temporary
or you're gonna help hustle for the
forever your soul is forever
absolutely you know you don't want to
cash that out you know what i'm saying
for temporary things for physical
you know what i mean i think that's the
ultimate test it's like yo you're going
to really be wealthy
meaning are you going to be happy or are
you going to look happy
you understand you're going to worry
about how people see you and buying
physical things that make you look
better than you are
or do you really want to really feel
good so how do you want to make money
i just want to see what i do right take
yourself to five years where do you want
to be in five years
see the thing about it is to shoot a
movie you need a script right you can't
just freestyle it
you can't say i want to say this or kind
of like that you got to be very direct
and then you put all your energy to what
you want you visualize it and then it
has to happen
i'm a filmmaker so you want to make
movies yeah i want to make i mean i've
done that but i want to do it to where i
don't have to worry about a regular job
yeah this is the way i would do it so i
would make as many short films as i can
just so people can start seeing that
you're good i would star in the movie if
i want to be anyone in this short film
like a real artist there's someone
that's damn near obsessed with it like a
painter should be painting eight hours a
day
a a band should be rehearsing eight
hours a day if you're a businessman you
should be doing your business
eight hours a day so if you're focused
on something and you're doing it
eight hours a day then you're doing it
at a professional level
but you got to know what you focused on
and then you can take things into your
own control
it doesn't happen overnight it's not
easy
expect pain expect anxiety expect
everything to go wrong and just be cool
breathe easy
and then just see it out because a lot
of people start but don't finish
when things don't happen in a way it's
never going to happen the way you want
it to happen
ever and if it does do not trust it it's
the devil
it's hard you do a lot and it's all
relative you know what i mean like the
first time i heard a record on the radio
i was excited the first time i saw my
video on television i was excited the
first time
i saw a movie at a theatrical level it
was very exciting you know
first times of anything are exciting and
i tend to have a lot of first times
you understand what i'm saying yeah
that's absolutely incredible so i try to
recreate that first time feeling by
doing new things you know traveling the
world is important opening up art
galleries
all over the world has been fun you know
opened up
an art gallery in hong kong was dope as
well as charleston as well as
the lower east side as well as tribeca
all of those
first times were great you know what i'm
saying being a different neighborhood
moving
and not being scared to you know have
growing pains
and things to that nature so it's all
been really fun
it's been a blast a business plan that's
about a business that doesn't exist
is a lot because you can't you can't say
like what are your facts based on
because it hasn't happened yet you can't
really determine who's gonna buy what
and how much it's gonna sell you can't
say i'm gonna make a million this year
did you make a million last year
no but what i'll do is put together what
it's like a script
i'll put together how to make the goods
how i'm going to market the goods
how much it's going to cost to buy the
goods what how what's my margin
and then when i'm going to sell it and
then how much i'm going to put back into
the business and how much i'm going to
put in my pocket
you know it's that kind of thing you
know i i write things out like
if you look one look on the um put that
on the wall right there right
as you can see you see the
piece of paper all that on the on the
that's the [ __ ] i got to do
you know i i like to put things on the
wall i can even know what i got to do i
need to look at it i need to cross it
out
i don't consider that a business plan
per se but i have a plan
you know what i'm saying like i have a
plan plus you want other people to
understand the plan because you can't do
anything on your own so you want to be
able to articulate it to them the way
they understand
and that they can look back at it
because i talk quick and like you said a
lot of times i say
you like i didn't understand that you're
not going to tell me until a year later
you know so you want to have something
someone could keep looking at and they
can see you crossing it off
and then they can kind of get it by
absorbing calls you know i support the
arts and i give people platforms you
know what i'm saying
like to me a real person that is
supposed to be a leader is supposed to
serve the people
you know what i'm saying that's what
you're supposed to do you're not
supposed to be worried about yourself
you know what i was i've been thinking
about lately
you notice that in the music business
traditionally it's the businessman
that's robbing the artist
and they always the artist ends up with
the with the behind the stories of where
they are now where they are now nobody
my artist that i ever touch a rich they
doing well and i'm the one that's always
looking broke
isn't that weird it's cause i give it
all away i'm not trying to take the
artist and have him in my pocket for his
life
and jerk him and have him resent me you
know what i'm saying i'm ready to get
him out my pocket be like look man go
win go eat go be yourself but leave me
alone
what i find is a lot of people are
really insecure about themselves they
don't think they're as interesting as
they are
so many people be so quick to make money
off other people's experiences
but you got your own like what's the
purpose of that it makes no say that
again yeah
and that's what i had to do that's what
you had to do right
once we started to believe in ourselves
we just work a little harder
but you end up reaping all the benefits
on it on your own terms and it feels 100
good and you can control the people you
around and it makes the most sense
i wanted to capitalize capitalize off
everything i thought i was the best at
so i thought i was the best at dressing
i didn't think nobody could dance better
than me so i thought i knew hit records
i knew i had the best most authentic
experiences
so i knew i'd make the best movies and i
just wanted to do all those things
but in hindsight i just like to do
because
i like to do it's fun i'm really
creative you know what i mean i just
like to be artistic
freely and you know it's like i don't
know
i just i just i just like doing it i
just thought you know i think i just i'm
having so much fun
and you know when you get success
relatively young it's like you know you
can settle but then you're gonna get
bored
so you know i was a mogul when i was in
my 20s so i was like i want to go do
fashion i want to go i want to run
around the world
i want everything i see or hear about i
want to see it personally i want to live
it i want to know what i want to touch
it how do you stay motivated and not get
burned out
i only do what i love you got to do what
you love you can't get burnt out and i
do get burnt out
you know once i'm in the business and i
don't enjoy it no more that's the thing
i can't it's hard for me to stay in the
business for a long period of time
because the people tend to make me sick
so as soon as i start to get aggravated
you know it's like i'll be on the block
if the block starts to make me mad i go
to another block
even if i got the block clicking it's
just like i won't compromise my quality
of living you know what i'm saying but
like right now
what i'm doing is you know i'm building
things that i could pass to my kids but
only things that i love
and my family so i love making movies
i'm making movies i love it i don't
think i'm gonna be burnt out with that
anytime soon
you know and then also when you're in
the business of making money off other
people
that person can make you sick and you
don't want to make money off them no
more so that's the reason why i try to
only make money off myself
these days and also do things that you
know my girl or my wife rocky
if she's inspired then we'll do that
business and like some revolving my
children i'll do that business
but i worked hard to put myself in that
position was there some pivotal moment
for you in your life where you just
really got it
and and something happened a fire
ignited inside you that made it
so that you had all the moving parts to
make this amazing career unfold
i think the death of my mother probably
got me really focused
and i understood that there wasn't going
to be anyone there to take care of me i
had to take care of myself
and just out of respect for her life and
all the things she did to make me a
better person
i had to apply all those things so you
know at like
17 my mother died when i was 16 and 17
you know i was running the streets so
heavy and it was getting so critical
that i put myself in boarding school you
know i figured out how to get a
scholarship and because of
the ability that my mother gave me to
articulate what's on my mind to read
to write you know to not be afraid and
also
i was you know boxing so i got went to
the boys club and
they were giving out scholarships for
you know you took a test i passed the
test and you know i made it
and uh i was just always able to to put
myself in a better
place i never let anybody else control
my destiny
my mom's taught me to uh make things
happen on my own not to depend on
anybody and if i have an opinion to
speak on it
if you had to sum up the your message
about
life what would you say i mean you know
my name is dame dash right and uh
what does the dash in between the
beginning of when you
born you die that dash that's the life
that's your life so
i think we're here to live we're here to
learn
you know we're not here to be perfect
we're supposed to embrace all our
imperfections
and i think if we find and can imagine
the bright side
in anything that will become a reality
but you can't think anything's going to
be given to you other than opportunity
and the only way to show appreciation
for opportunity is to react
not to say thank you but to actually do
something
and not everyone gets opportunities so i
think
appreciating those opportunities is
really important because
the next time those opportunities will
not be presented and i think
every single day for everybody there's a
lesson
there's a test and if you don't pass the
test you do not move forward
you stay in the same place and then that
test becomes a little harder and if you
don't pass it again
you actually go backwards and then
instead of the test being in front of
you
where you can look at the test and sit
back at you and it's smacking the [ __ ]
out of you in the back of your head
and it hurts and it's embarrassing so i
always advise people to look out for
those tests
not the ones when people are looking
just when no one's looking define the
culture culture there
it's someone that exploits a culture and
benefits from a culture that it doesn't
help
you know period that it just hurts and
it just sucks out everything from it but
it could give a [ __ ] about it
that's a culture vulture you know and
it happens more times than that i mean i
mean it's all over the place well
creative people
usually aren't so worried well creative
people usually aren't so worried about
monetization you know they want to pay
their bills but non-creative people
are solely making money off of a
creative and i don't get the creative
people and they
and it means they come to kind of have
to rob them at a young age
i remember getting yelled at in in
nursery school
like i was four or five and i felt this
feeling of embarrassment
and at that moment i was able to
identify that feeling
and i was like i will never let myself
feel embarrassed again
so from then on nothing young age yeah
i would just you know i didn't like the
feeling like i felt funny i felt like i
was shrinking like you know what fred
flintstone gets yelled at and you
get smaller yeah i didn't like anybody
making me feel smaller just
by the energy of their voice so it was
almost like i put this repellent on
where nothing could embarrass me you
know what i'm saying so
i just never really cared and i never
wanted to be a part of a crowd i always
wanted to be an individual i hated when
everybody looked the same so it was like
it was corny to me to like
to like something because somebody else
liked it so i was like that guy that was
like if you like it i'm not gonna like
it
you know i always wanted to be first
never be last i never wanted to like
follow a trend i've always wanted to
start it
and i think that comes from the harlem
swag and all that and that confidence is
what made me not really care so
when i would speak about things that no
one else was speaking about or if i was
gonna do something that no one else did
i embraced that loneliness you know
because it meant i was doing something
right
where other people right and as a result
of it because i would always give 100
fearlessly and stand behind my point of
view i always got the reception that i
thought that i deserved which was you
know being able to have the life that i
wanted
again recognize what really makes you
happy if you feel like you lose and
you're losing it doesn't matter what
other people feel
so i know how it feels to be perceived
as winning and be feeling like uh i'm
losing
i stopped living according to what
people wanted me to do
i started living according to what
actually made me happy
like if you're in a situation that don't
make no sense then get out of it don't
make it make sense
one plus one always equals two if you're
not happy change your life
entrepreneurial ship is in everyone but
not everyone has the discipline for but
anyone could be an entrepreneur
but not everyone wants to be an
entrepreneur some people rather
depend on other people because they feel
like they don't have to work as hard
but being an entrepreneur means working
hard it means embracing struggle
it means being a leader and never
sending somebody to do something that
you wouldn't do yourself
a real boss would never send somebody to
do something they wouldn't do themselves
a boss that tells somebody to do
something that they wouldn't do is not a
boss he's a cop
and i that that those principles came to
me from the people i knew in the street
right so somebody's gonna be like you'll
kill that [ __ ] for me but you know
you're killing yourself
i know all about you understand what i'm
saying you're a guy that'll be pushing
but you don't do nothing you're not a
real boss fight
expect expect to be uncomfortable and if
you're not devoting
between eight and 12 hours a day on your
craft then you're not really trying to
be a professional
right like you got to realize you you're
trying to be competitive being a
professional means being the best in the
world
that's that doesn't just come with skill
that comes with discipline right
you know that means you have to have a
certain kind of work ethic that means
you're doing things that most won't
right people really don't understand it
like they think they got skills so
everything is going to come to them
skill is
actually like a curse i've seen people
with no skill that realize it
and understand that they have to work
hard to get this skill work so hard that
they do better than the people that have
skill
and that are arrogant and entitled that
feel that it should just come to them
and then they just become a waste
you know having potential is if you
don't realize it right it becomes corny
like you're the cool guy when you have
potential but like 10 years later if you
don't realize it then you're the corny
guy
right you know what i'm saying and i
never want to ever be that guy so people
who take the leap and they make that fir
they take that first passion and build a
business or they start something
but they have other talents or other
disciplines that they want to build
things around
how have you managed to build multiple
companies or take that blueprint and
apply it to different
areas and manage that it's because i
look at
all the little companies as marketing
for one company when i make a movie i
got to make the movie
right so i got to do that but also after
i make the movie i got to distribute the
movie so i'm going to build the platform
like dame dare studios or whatever app
i'ma distribute it
you know what i'm saying then while
you're watching the movie like you got
to wear clothes i wear clothes
i like to make clothes i have the
ability to do it i was in the fashion
business still am
so i make all the clothes it's a
commercial for the clothes i like music
but not in a traditional sense i don't
want to monetize and
exploit artists but i do have a deep
catalog of music that i've made while i
was just inspired in the moment
i could use the music in the movie so
now you can sell the music you sell into
fashion
people drink right so why won't you
drink the liquor that i make i make the
liquor so then now you can you know
drink the liquor
but i'm just saying so everything you
see i feel like i want to make because i
have the ability to do it you know what
i'm saying so i do it
so i basically leverage the things that
people pay for
that's what i use for marketing so i've
always looked at look at rockwear look
at state property when i have a movie
called
state property then you've got clothing
called state property you have
alabama called state property state
property did 20-something million and
closed that year just because of the
commercial
that the movie presents why would i pay
somebody to do something i could do
myself
like why am i pay a bodyguard when i
could fight what i try to do when i
start companies
is learn every single job before we
start hiring
so for example with damn dance studios i
actually got boogie running damn dad
studios and raquel
you know editing and posting and doing
the things so that when they hire
somebody they'll know what to tell them
to do
and they'll know how long it takes and
they'll know if that person is doing
their job or not
i tried to bring everybody that was like
kind of doing it at the time i'm not
gonna say no names but
if you know every name i'm talking about
put them in a room raise the money
and one just would not do it it's just
like
why don't we want to have that power
it's like the more power we give each
other
people start to think they're taking it
away from themselves right it's like
people don't understand when you share
all of us together are way stronger than
us being alone you know i mean an army
is
always better than a single person if
they're all in the same paper
everyone can always equally win because
that way you could never lose
if i borrow a little bit from everybody
in this room i'm rich so i'm gonna keep
y'all rich as my friends so you can make
sure because i spend all my money
so i can make sure i'm right you know i
need a favor
you know what i'm saying like the only
purpose for me to make everyone that i
made famous is so that they can help me
without putting up a dollar
so if it really come down to it jay i
need you to instagram that yo kanye just
do that
it don't cost a dollar to twitter
something out for me all i need is for
you to leverage your celebrity it
doesn't cost you a dollar just bring
attention to my brands
that's what i made you famous for if we
stick together that way we cannot lose
i haven't got that deal yet you know
what i mean
you know like it's all relative like you
know if you're in the street the first
time you get a bird it's a big deal like
oh
i got a bird you know that's that's the
success of uh for like someone in music
like being on the radio might be
the biggest deal but then you know or
the first time you get a tour bus so the
first time you perform at the garden
you know there's so many different
things so
like things that i thought were big once
i get them pause they're not big to me
no more like once you
make your first million like man quickly
like that wasn't nothing right
that can't be big i did too much too
too young to to give it up to even be
impressed with myself yet
you know i have bigger dreams than
trying to be getting
a salary from some company you know i
need to own something i need a legacy
you know like
the dashes are going to be they are i
already know it we're going to be like
the kennedys and
and the in the vander you know we're
going to be an upstanding family
that's what i wanted to build that's
what i mean but that's what i'm saying i
wanted it easy for my kids and i want it
easy for my kids kids
and that's all i'm doing right now just
making sure that the company can run
when i'm not around
you know what i'm saying family and
company that's what that's what that's
what you know
it has to be able to sustain everybody
says they want to be the boss
but people be scared to be the boss most
people are scared to put up their own
money
most people are scared to tell people to
work when they don't want to
most people are scared to even ask for
their money you understand what i'm
saying like
people i see people that are
uncomfortable about asking about their
own business
like asking for change you know i'm
saying or asking how much do you get
paid or
when am i gonna get paid or where's my
money i had never felt uncomfortable
about asking for my bread
and i've never understood people that
were uncomfortable for asking for their
bread
and i really don't understand people
that are offended by you asking for your
bread
right you know you ask somebody for
their money and they're like what you
asking like
i'm not supposed to ask for my money am
i supposed to ask about my money like
the money and the business
there should be no emotion with asking
about it because it's business
there should be no fear you should never
be ashamed to ask for your change
ever you know or to scrutinize the bill
after my daughters were born
i shut down everything i was doing i
invested all my money into at rachel roy
and then i just opened up art galleries
where creative people could come and
coexist and make things happen without
um compromise the quality of living
yeah so i opened up dd-172 which was a
10 000
square foot gallery in the most
expensive real estate in manhattan in
tribeca
and you know i had people like most deaf
and jay electronica and wiz khalifa
and currency and it just goes on rock
and roll the black keys
you know the holy ghost um um erica badu
all performing i had an internet
television station called creative
control this was in 2009. so you're
ahead of the curve on that stuff
i'm always ahead of the curve you want
to know the future just ask me
do you think bosses are born or are they
made
i think everyone has the potential to be
a boss
i think you are born a boss and made a
slave no one's going to choose to be a
slave
who want to be a slave you got to be
trained to think
that life is good when it's not yeah
you're born a boss until somebody
convinces you you're not
yeah i'm born the boss if i can breathe
and i'm controlling that
i'm a boss and anything i own is mine
no matter who you are you cannot come in
here unless if i'm not breaking no laws
do not come in here
and if you do it's on my terms are you
breaking the law
you know and i can be confident arrogant
about that as long as i'm not breaking
no laws
i just don't see the reason for being
mad about making mistakes like
i just i just i don't know man
i think i got yelled at one time when i
was four and i felt embarrassed
and i didn't like that feeling so i did
what the guy did with the cold i figured
out how to never be embarrassed
you know what i'm saying teach me how
you just don't give up once you don't
give up
what people think like logically
speaking why would you care
about what someone's opinion is that you
don't love that doesn't love you that's
not even playing the same game you're
playing
that's only you know the only reason why
they have something to say is because
they're insecure
like i don't i just i don't see why i
would be concerned about some insecure
like i i think one million lames
combined
cannot equal one cool person and meaning
someone that's just honest about who
they are like
being it's not relatable it's not
realistic to think that
anyone is perfect and anyone that is is
evil
because it's just not true you know what
i'm saying
and the good thing about imperfections
is what makes you cool is
how you deal with them that's what makes
you cool
you know what i'm saying so i've never
been afraid to be wrong
i always remember back to when i was
young laughing at older [ __ ]
i'm never going to be there older [ __ ]
i was laughing at i'm never going to be
that old man in the club
i'm never going to beat a dude that you
know just because that one time i water
outfit
everyone thought i was fly i'm aware for
the next 30 years
like i'm not doing that you know what
i'm saying i'm going to evolve i'm going
to grow
so it's not reinventing it's if you're
learning what i learned as i learn it
i'm just
i'm growing once i learned this business
was whack i did another one
you know and i said [ __ ] it i'm gonna go
do art my midlife crisis was running
around the world open up art galleries
you know i like to do fly cool like
i bank on cool i just like to do cool
you know so i don't i just think i and i
got to be smart about it like i got to
be the plug i got to be the connect
so once i know how to do it myself i
could be real arrogant about it
and then i do it and then when i win
it's like when everyone thinks you're
losing and you win it's so much better
but the [ __ ] was making me an
underdog i was cracking up i think it's
funny as a
you know what i'm saying you know and i
can be patient i think i'm gonna do it
by the pool
you know what i'm saying like i come out
when i feel like it you know it's never
been urgent
i've never felt i've never felt my my
batman or the joker
i haven't found my competition yet that
inspires me to fight
i just feel like impressing my girl and
my family and me i don't even feel no
competition
independence is priceless it's just
people that have never had it don't even
understand
and i don't even expect them to you know
and
independence means usually putting up
your own bill
you have to put up your own way that's
independence if
someone else is putting up the money
that's dependence
you understand what i'm saying you know
you got to move when they say
you have to ask you have to be nice you
have to laugh at jokes that aren't funny
you know what i mean you have to be
around a racist and let them say little
things little cute things
a nerd square that wouldn't survive in
the street
and independence is like being
[Applause]
like let me tell you the perspective of
someone that's independent
if there's like a a wild dog and he has
to
literally eat the food he kills he
cannot eat unless he kills something
that day
and then there's a girl that's changed
he lives in a house but he has three
square meals a day he got to do tricks
he gets petted he gets kicked out he
gets beat he's got to get walked he
walks on a leash
when that dog comes in the room with the
wild dog the wild dog is laughing
he doesn't care that you're in the
mansion he doesn't care that you eat
a steak every day he still thinks you're
hurt he knows he can take from you
because he knows he has to kill every
day to eat
you know what i mean and that's a
confidence that's a rock star
and that's the one thing that i know i
would never give up
you know the ability to be that like i
laugh at anyone that's a caged dog
you know walked on a leash told when to
eat and does tricks and rolls over for a
check
why is it so hard to bet on yourself for
a lot of people like what's going hard
why why is that so hard for people to do
to pull up their own money and better
themselves
when they see it really works out
eventually because when you put up your
money that's a struggle
and a lot of people don't just want to
walk into a struggle
i know it's like some people don't even
know they could fight they're not
really you know have the discipline to
go to training camp and
really focus and and see it through and
like they don't want to walk into
the struggle to win you have to to want
to win
means you have to embrace pain you have
to embrace struggle you know what i'm
saying like you have to know that
nothing's going to be easy in order to
be the best at it in the world
you have to do it and push yourself
where most people won't you know what
i'm saying you got to be up for that man
you know what i'm saying like you if you
up for it you can do it but not
everybody's up for it
but not everybody really conceptually
they want it
but do they want the pain it takes to go
get it and i have a lot like these
people that
like there's things about them i don't
like but i respect the fact that they're
going to fight to get what they want
the fight and regardless of whether our
perspective is different and not
that fight every time whether it's wrong
or right
you're the person that fights the
hardest wins you really ultimately know
that if you really believe in yourself
and you work
hard at it you'll achieve it the
question is
am i ready to work so hard that i'm
better than everyone else
you understand what i'm saying and you
have to answer that question within
yourself
am i ready to embrace all the pain that
nobody else wants to embrace
yeah am i ready to really work harder
and do it so much that i'm better at it
than everyone that does it
it's really about the work ethic really
it's a professional work ethic you can't
just be good at something
you have to be able to to see things
through and do the things that you don't
enjoy
it's not really about the things that
you enjoy that's the easy part it's the
things you don't enjoy that's the things
that people usually shut down about they
just don't like it
just because you don't like something
doesn't mean it's a failure what i do is
i'm a businessman right in any business
the more crowded it is the harder it is
to do it so i never want to hustle on a
crowded block
so regardless to what i'm always looking
to do something that nobody's doing so
all i was looking is was what's the next
wave
logically it was just logically i was
paying attention you know what i'm
saying so once i realized that i was
like it's the internet this freedom was
ridiculous and plus like it was like
damn if i know how to make this
myself like content is like currency
it's the thing that makes money forever
and ever
so it's like it's like when somebody
smokes a joint the weed is gone you got
to grow more weed when somebody looks at
something you could pay over and over
again to see it and you ain't got to
keep making it
i just look at what people pay for and
do it myself i'm the plug i'm never a
customer do it yourself and leverage
your own celebrity right so instead of
letting somebody else make
it we make it and then we don't have to
pay for the marketing it's easy
so now that i'm a brand for doing that i
can now completely invest in myself
but there's two games one is making good
work and one is leveraging celebrity
right
the good work you ain't got to move good
work they find you you ain't gotta
promote your destination
when you ain't doing too good that's
when there's the over compensation you
start hitting red carpets every day and
doing other
to distract the fact that you have no
talent you understand what i'm saying
there are so many amazing talent
performers that came out of new york
in the late 80s in the early 90s mary j
biggie jay-z the firm and you were
like a big part of that did you realize
at the time how big that movement was
going to be
and then what it was going to mean for
the rest of the world and the rest of
the music scene yeah i did
i did you could feel it at the time yeah
every i knew that that's why
i was the person that was documenting
everything because i knew everything i
was doing in that moment was legendary
so the way i would look at it would be
like damn could you imagine if you had
jimi hendrix and david bowie
and john lennon before they cracked or
mick jagger in like a studio or just
kicking it before they got famous and
then imagine when they did
so because i was so confident in
everything i was doing and all the
people around me
i knew that what we were doing would
probably set the stage for history you
know what i'm saying
i didn't think anybody was cooler than
us and i knew it actually and it you
know it turned out i was right
you know in all them i'm from harlem we
had a crew called the best out
and we sit through parties and um at the
cotton club we had kick capri dj and we
used to make t-shirts
and we had our names on them and we used
to have basketball games
and a lot of people tried to do what we
were doing we were emulated like i
remember when we were throwing our
basketball games would be like
us the best out versus kev childs crew
they were called boss and it was crazy
at the gaucho gym
and then the next thing i would see puff
do a basketball thing but you know it
ended up being tragic
but i knew that he was influenced by
what we was doing so i've always so
seen how my influence has been on the
rest of the world from day one
and it still is like that people still
you know take what i do and they're
influenced by it that's why i think
at this point my life at 46 it's
important to do things that are positive
so are people going to emulate what i'm
doing they're emulating something
positive
like eating healthy like taking care of
yourself like being
good to women and taking care of your
woman being a good dad like loving your
children like to me that's ultimate
wealth
loyalty is not convenient if you only
can't just be loyal when it's like easy
convenient you know what i'm saying yeah
like if there's a bag of money
but you got to do the wrong thing and be
disloyal to somebody
friends yeah you know what i mean just
you know
so sometimes you know respect to me
guides you and and protects you from
everything
you if you leave with respect on
anything the right things will happen
you understand what i've never seen
respect put anyone in harm's way
i've only seen respect always always
protect you and then also the ultimate
test is always
like to disrespect the people you love
to get something physical
like some bread you understand what i'm
saying that's the test
i mean and tests aren't meant to be easy
you know what i'm saying like that's
what my test would always be it would be
like
am i going to play my culture am i going
to get that dollar you understand
i just couldn't do it because that might
be my family there's many times i'm sure
you could have played
all the time all the time you know that
was my problem with the music business
because it was such
it was such a disloyalty to my culture
to exploit it the way it was being
exploited and letting other cultures
exploit it not saying
and being like it's alright just because
i'm making money so just because i'm all
right
makes it up you know because i i fought
through it it still didn't make it all
right to just sit there and watch them
all the rest of the culture to me
that's why i always fought for it you
know what i mean there was like guilt
with it always
you know i mean just being around people
i didn't want to be around when people
make me the underdog it's funny because
they don't understand what the game i'm
playing just because i'm not playing
your game
or just because i'm not moving at the
pace you're moving it don't mean i'm
wrong
you know what i'm saying you're winning
the same win is mine and it's never been
like what i've always liked when someone
thought a record there was dope i was
like a label deal
you understand like you got a record
deal you should have a label
you might have a tv show you should have
a network you know that's just how i
think
right i have boss thoughts i'm always
thinking
i don't know what chapter right there
boss starts i
i don't know any other language but boss
boss language you know what i'm saying
so when people don't talk and boss to me
i don't know what they say you know what
i'm saying it's a language it's there's
approaches
like people approach things like bosses
and people approach things like workers
a lot of people don't want to be bosses
because there's so much responsibility
that come with it
you understand they're scared of it and
i always say that you understand what
i'm saying
right but a boss only can think about it
in boss terms
so if somebody says they want to get in
business some people might say well i
need somebody to give me a job
that's not a broad start right a boss
says if i want to get better my thought
is if i want to get in business
i'm going to create the business figure
i'm gonna buy the business
you understand what i'm saying then i'm
gonna do the business but i'm not trying
to be hired
my approach is always gonna be bossy you
know someone that's not used to being
the boss
his thought process ain't possible we
don't have boss
[Music]
and if you don't talk to me in boston i
don't understand what you say
i'm saying that's foreign not
celebrating that that you got to do
your boss talk is like i speak that yeah
you can tell what somebody else talks
boss just by their approach or thing
and someone that talks boss doesn't
speak any other language
i only talk boss the minute i had
daughters i was like i got to change
everything i can't do anything to a girl
that i don't want another man to do to
my daughter
so that was a real turning point for you
the daughter's for sure my daughter's
changed my life for my um
second daughter tallulah was born i
decided to quit everything
to make sure that anything i did i put
her first not not the business
she before it was like business first
because i got to pay for the kids but
it's like if you're not there to spend
the money with your kids it really
doesn't matter they need you and your
company
so and and i saw all the things i was
missing so you know what you think i'd
rather do be on a yacht pouring
champagne or a girl or taking my
daughter to get a cupcake
it's nothing better than taking your
daughter to get a cupcake you know
there's nothing better than watching
your baby smile
you know so it's true you know but i
it's like seems obvious but you know
lotto
is really like energy it's love it's not
like physical money which really doesn't
mean anything it's just how good you
make someone feel it's how good
your woman feels how good your children
feel like you have
as much money as you know billions of
dollars but if you unhappy and you're
lonely
you're broke if your kids are unhappy
you're broke
you know if your woman's unhappy you
broke it's all about effort and what you
could visualize in your mind
you know if you can't think it could
happen and if you don't have confidence
that it's gonna happen it ain't gonna
happen
so if you doubt yourself like you know i
box or at least i used to
i'm not getting in the ring unless i
know i'm a win or else i already lost
and i look at everything i do like that
i'm winning and there is nothing
it's 100 everything is about perspective
and what you consider a win
you know some people think they're
winning because
other people think they're winning even
though they don't feel good about what
they're doing
they're like oh you think i'm winning so
that must mean i'm winning but i feel
like
that's not winning you know you have to
know what makes you happy what you
considering not everybody's win is the
same
you know what i'm saying but people like
to fit in with aws but not me
the reason why people take jobs is
because they got to pay their bills when
you say be a boss to be independent
everybody should be an entrepreneur
everyone has an apartment right you're
the boss in your apartment right
no matter what no matter how little it
is if it's whether it's a big house or a
little house that
space right there you're the boss that's
what your business is that's what your
life is you create the space so you can
control it you control your environment
but you have to art detect that
you want to live in the house build it
you know what i'm saying i'm going to
give it to you
but once you get in that house i don't
care if the president or whoever it is
anywhere he walked in my house obama you
still got to listen to me in this house
people think it's safe to have a job but
if somebody can fire you how is that
safe
period like you got to be nice to
somebody if they don't like you they can
fire you and if they the people that can
fire you don't be owning a
neighbor they'd be supervisors so then
it becomes like political
there's no politics when you're the boss
it's my way or no way because i believe
that you see that at any point no matter
how much you contribute that whole thing
can be taken away
at any particular time right so how does
somebody then go
and just make that shift to the same
they're doing for somebody else
do it for yourself right if you're a
paid editor edit your own movie you're a
paid writer right at your own
magazine you know it's like the thing is
nobody ever gave me anything no one gave
me real no record deal i had to do it
myself
right so imagine if i would have waited
for a deal for jay-z there'd be no jay-z
there'd be no kanye there'd be no lee
daniels there'd be no kevin hart they'd
be no rachel roy
none of that do you know what i'm saying
none of them any
i had to build all that like no one's
gonna hire me to direct you know what i
mean no one's gonna hire me to be the
ceo of a company
i made the company i'm the ceo of it
period how do you feel about rockefeller
today
is the same attitude that i think it's a
shame it doesn't exist anymore
you know i think the way that it
dissolved was kind of selfish but i'm
going to get into that
you know what i'm saying but it would
have been nice to see everybody doing
well as opposed to one person and that's
the way i wanted rockefeller i made it
you know i believe in the circle of
success where everybody gets rich
i don't want to make employees i want to
make bosses yeah it's more of a family
enterprise well it was
you know but then it turned out to be
one person stayed rich and everyone else
had to work for them and that's not how
i
looked at rockefeller and what i
realized is i need to make and invest in
things that i could pass to my family so
i had to invest more in myself as
opposed to investing in other people
because not everybody has the same idea
ideal
ideology as me you know what i'm saying
not everybody
you know looks at things the same way so
you know i should have probably paid a
little more attention than making assets
that i own as opposed to making other
people because
my thing was i was putting people in
power so that they could put us in power
but every time i put somebody in power
they would shut the door and they just
wanted all the power
people get hungry as soon as they get
it's just human nature it's how menards
the testosterone in them that's why i
also surround myself more with women
because men women don't tend to be so
jealous
do you think that's more of an
exclusively male thing then the females
aren't as like hungry when they get in
that position i think
males are so supremely insecure that
they turn into clowns a lot of people
will cheat and try to
cut corners but i don't consider that a
win you know what i'm saying like if i
know the game i'm playing and i start
going to it
that's the only way i want to win at it
i don't want to cheat to get there
because then i didn't win at my game i
actually lost you actually lost you
don't understand but you know i'm not
going to play your game i only play
you only achieve when you don't fully
believe in your abilities in the first
place yeah it's over compensation
for sure but then that's like a
different kind of win you know you play
in a different game
we have chapters in our life yes you
know the cool thing about the way i
approach thing is i always have like an
ill bucket list
you know what i'm saying and there'll be
there's a bunch of things that i want to
do in my life
and eventually i know i'm gonna do it
okay so young i wanted to hustle
i got that off my bucket list quick you
understand i wanted to be a music mogul
off my bucket list i wanted to be a
fashion mogul off my bucket list i
wanted to sell oil
off my bucket list i wanted to have art
galleries off my bucket list
and the things that were like on my
bucket list for things like i'd be like
even though you saw it in the book one
day i'm gonna do a diabetes network i'm
gonna do something that's just about
diabetes
i did it yeah it's off my bucket list
you understand what i'm saying
one of the things on my bucket list is
to own a football team one of my things
on my bucket list is
to have a network you know a real
channel
to have a hotel so there's always like a
chapter in my life where i attack that
bucket list
one of the things on our bucket list is
to grow land you understand what i'm
saying and to be able to have a
farm i was trying to grow cotton make
the clothes from the cotton to be
completely vertical that's what we were
trying to do in north carolina
i think when you have consciousness you
become responsible
you know and i think the truth is a
heavy burden because usually the truth
teller gets
gets crucified like jesus you know the
person that tells the truth is always
going to have to fight the people that
are lying
and because the people that are lying or
cheating you're not fighting the same
fight like
that they'll do you won't do so how do
you protect yourself
you got to be extra strong you got to be
like batman you got to be like a
superhero but look that as a criminal
it's a life you got to choose and that's
the life that i did choose because life
has been so easy for me
i've had so much fun every second i
benefited and monetized my
my everything that i love at every time
you know i'm 47 years old i'll be 47 in
may
what else should i do you know what i'm
saying like and plus
i don't like the people that are taking
advantage in front and i think they're
soft
and i want everybody to know so that's
why i call out names like
leo cohen and charlie wok and barry
barry uh what's it clock thinking about
barry clawberg you know steve stout
all of those people that i feel have
done that and have really taken
advantage i think
i don't want other people to get taken
advantage of
so that's like if you see a child
molester in the neighborhood it's your
responsibility to say yo don't have your
kids
around them and i love my culture like
they're my children they're not my
children i'm not being that cocky but we
all family
so i'm gonna look out for my cousins and
my family at all times i first got
record deals
and i didn't like the experience of it
you know
they were they were telling me i just it
didn't work out
and i had jay-z had jay-z and i was
shopping jay-z
and they were every single person in the
music business i took him to every
single label
and they told me he was too old too
corny
nothing just damn near laughed me out
every one of them could not see where he
was so we had to do it ourself
sure so off top we kind of because when
you're the plug in the street
you think like the plug everywhere yeah
so i'm thinking who's the boss here
who do i need to talk to there is no
boss in corporate because no one really
owns it it's public
so i was like i got to do this on my own
so we did it on our own so
knowing that we had the best rapper on
the planet knowing that these were the
lanes that were making those decisions
that that business model never worked
for us so we decided to make our own
business model
and do it on our own where we never had
to compromise any integrity
or any or compromise of equity i would
love to know what your outlook is when
you
in your past have had a setback how do
you you never had a setback but death
okay that's the only setback is health
and death in jail
other than that those are just life
tests so like what's a setback like if a
friend comes to you and they feel like
they failed at something
what would you tell them to change that
perspective of the word failure turn the
loss into a learning experience do it
again until you get it right period
you never did anything right the first
time practice makes perfect it's just
like you ain't gonna make a muscle the
first time you pick up a bar
you gotta do that and do it for a while
then your blood pumps and then you
strong go get strong pull your skirt up
that's what i'm saying i'm not gonna be
nice about it i'm sick of that
everybody's depressed because they're
trying to fit into a puzzle they're
trying to be a
circle in the square and you you're told
what to do and you're told what to eat
and you're told what's good and bad and
what the perspective of successes
success is love success is your family
success is how much you laugh
i don't care how much money you got in
the bank if you got a crooked smile
if your people around you don't want to
be around your breath stinks and all
that
you're broke like just
to relax i mean you're always running
what do you do to like just
other than the kids just is there
something you meditate
i smoke weed i lay by the pool a lot
good like you know this is cool like i
wasn't here all day you know what i'm
saying i
came in when i felt like it i went got
my daughter came back went back
you know i was sweating there's a living
life but i'm doing it on my terms
you know i'm doing it like like i'm i'm
productive
but i'm not tired because i'm when
you're doing what you love like
everything i'm doing i would do for free
this like i'm lucky enough that i can
monetize what people do for recreation
you know what i'm saying so how can i
ever complain and be tired
i'm having way too much fun to be tired
how did you apply the stuff from the
street to the business world well let me
explain it to you
so when you deal with a bunch of people
that are tamed and you're a wild animal
you get in a room you laugh at them you
don't be scared of them
i always thought they were a joke
because i had executed business under a
different circumstances so i always
thought they were funny
and also because they were working for
other people and i was putting up my own
money
i didn't really respect as much like you
know boss wants to talk to another boss
so it made me know not to be corporate
when i went into that world i went very
arrogantly i didn't feel like
because i was always ahead of the game i
got my first deal at 19.
you know what i mean so i felt like the
people that i was dealing with
shouldn't even be talking to me a
certain way even telling me what's cool
because they were nerdy to me
what we were leveraging in that point
was cool i was selling music
swag i was coming from the authentic
street like in the 80s so it wasn't
nothing that you could tell me
and then i had a mind because i was
educated so i saw them trying to trick
me into believing i was dumber than i
was
so for that i was a beast it was it was
just like
it was a joke you know what i mean so i
did it we just did it on our own so
you took her personally you're offended
i mean it sounds like you were offended
i mean i'm passionate about everything
i'm doing this is about creative
business
okay so of course when someone
disrespects your intellect you take it
personal i'm a man i got testosterone
for sure sure but that's part of being
an entrepreneur you know what i'm saying
but also i'm coming from a place where i
had to fight for my real estate and
prove that you shouldn't have it
so certain kinds of people can never
talk to me a certain way you understand
what i'm saying
just because they didn't they weren't
men like i was men again they weren't
taking they weren't
putting up their own money they didn't
have the cool and they weren't doing
what i was doing it was like i knew
always my worth at all times and i
always knew what my brain was
capable of doing i come from a very
extreme circumstance you know i come
like front line street
like 142nd and linux and if you did
break any of those laws you died or went
to jail so i didn't have too many
choices
so i don't really know no different you
know what i mean so i just applied
everything i
learned from my survival skills and
obviously i survived and i came again
from a very dangerous place
i survived it just by being honorable
playing the game right
being loyal and i was like yo this game
right here is not sustainable [ __ ] die
being honorable means you got to kill
when they disrespect you you got to go
to jail and not you know all that type
that's not a game i want to play i'ma
just take these ideals
and apply them instead of to crack apply
it to music
instead of to dust apply it to fashion
it's just taking the same principles and
applying it and everything i've learned
really has come from hustling it's just
flipping
right now you buy something you you you
bottle it up you sell it
you make double and then you put that
back and you keep doing it so once you
know that
discipline why else do you need why do
you need anybody like i never wanted
anybody to hit me with no work i didn't
i never wanted that
what i saw in kanye's face when he was
helping us
is something that people don't get when
you help people that deserves it it
gives you a really good feeling it makes
you feel better than anything
i saw him smiling and laughing and i was
like he gets it now
because that's how i feel every time i
help somebody get where they got to go
and you know i did it just because i
wanted to just because i was inspired
not because
i was trying to exploit him but just
because i really liked who they were and
what they were doing
and i want that to be a contagious
energy and i really hope that overall
that's what honor up does
it makes honor up be the new wave
looking out for the people that looked
out for you
doing the right thing i'm a very
sophisticated guy you know i mean i have
good taste
right great and i've always loved art
and only thing you need to make a
gallery is walls
mm-hmm so you know instead it's just a
narrative i call it a gallery as a
gallery and i put art on it and people
come in if they buy the art i get 50
of them that's the art business but what
it does is it brings very artistic
people together
so you know art brings all kind of
creatives together actually
i always have a collective so because
when someone's good at editing they're
usually good at a lot of other things
somebody's good at rapping or singing
they're good at acting they're good at
painting like
creators are just creatives and you know
sometimes people only do what they think
they can do if you don't know the
business you just say oh i can't do it
so i don't just like an art gallery
see me i'm always thinking on how to do
it and it's usually not that hard and
then also look at who does it then i
compare myself right yeah like
i could do it you know i did the record
labels 10 years ago so i couldn't go
back
be like you know pitching nickels to me
just because i did it before
no disrespect to the company or to the
music industry because there's a lot of
bread there just i did it
so you know the expectation of myself is
to do something that you know
fits the levels that i should be at and
what i noticed was you know number one
we were outsourcing so much
shooting music videos and we're making
the clothes
and you know you know i like to make
movies it just made sense for me to have
my own television network
and you know when the internet hit
because i'm always looking for
independence
i was like oh i could do it and i didn't
feel the need to outsource like i always
feel like a johnny
if i'm paying somebody to do something i
know i could do myself
like i always feel like the plug i can
grow that i ain't buying it from you
i'll go in the cellar
tree you know that's my approach on
things so i also feel that i'm also
really good at making films
so because i can make films make moves i
understand the game i really
like ran the cash register there and
because i have a business mind
i'ma invest in that honestly every
single second of my life has meant
and everyone else's life i think is
meant to be a learning experience
so when something happens that didn't go
the way you wanted it to
you look at what you learned from it
right
and there's been businesses that i've
got completely robbed
for short paper but what i learned from
it protected me from getting robbed for
big paper
you understand what i'm saying so at the
end of the day
i'm so happy in this very moment
i'm so happy
like scary happy
you know what i mean yeah i think that's
like the misconception that you're not
in the matter in the middle in the
middle of a pandemic
all my dreams are coming true
which is crazy to me so i would have to
say
if there was anything that would stop me
from being this happy now
or that would change it was like is
there anything i could have done
that could have made me as happy as i am
now i'm happy now
because every decision that most people
thought would be tough
every business i walked away from every
person i walked away from
every person that i punished that
everyone told me not to
from a leo cohen to a harvey weinstein
i'm glad i did it i'm glad i was in a
position to do it
i'm glad i'm that guy that these guys
are known to be bullies and i bullied
them
i'm the bully of bullies i'm happy about
that so
i love the fact that these challenges
and these tests have presented
themselves to me
and i could get in the shower i'm like
damn i really am a
superhero i never ever waver when it
comes to honor never have i walked away
from people that no one would walk away
from
i barked on people that no one would
bark on until
everyone is barking on i did it alone
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you get motivated
the sign says you have a 35 chance of
following through
that's not enough but when you write
down what time what place
and how you're going to actually take
action on it you jump to 91
chance of following through and when you
have public accountability and you
commit
to other people that you're going to do
it it jumps to 95
that you will follow through so i want
that for you believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you the win should be when you have one
by your standard but not someone else's
because what people are generally like
insecure
and people generally look the other way
they do things that are illogical and
they all have their own set of problems
so everyone considers a win different
so why would i consider my win something
that makes you happy i'm going to
consider my win something that makes me
and my family and my kids and my girl
happy right what i'm saying
i don't want to look like i'm rich to
make you happy i need to be rich right
so guys think they're rich because they
might have
monetary like like very very like
temporary money that they could take
care of themselves
right that's not rich rich is being able
to take care of your kids kids
right being able to make it with your
generation or the generation before
after you doesn't have to go through the
same problems as you did
if you want some awesome inspiration
from eric thomas check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i think people get so excited
about the
dreaming part that they have no idea
like what it really takes and so i need
to do me a huge favor